welcome to this video playing Argo koi
huh funny I have never played him that's
surprising he doesn't have a name there
right no it feels like I definitely
haven't played him but not recently in
the on the videos maybe some some time
ago yeah we have a trump here from
Bosque opening with them well not a a
player somewhat unambitious set up there
admittedly 95 mm okay
there that's interesting he's trying to
exploit that this Bishop b5 b5 move nose
in the air and I don't really want to
play a six Bishop b5 is something to
avoid
hmm and Queen b6 is very slow oh I don't
like it so much but I came I hope I'm uh
still I'm still all right here
I've lost a bit of time here with this
ninety-four business okay well these
kind of moves shouldn't be so dangerous
I really was thinking I was more afraid
of I'm not sure something was c4
something that opens the position the
bishop on g4 also prevents canceling at
the moment if I could see for them okay
can go to see - yeah I know I'm
neglecting development Jim I hope no you
one of my students is watching office
tell them to develop sometimes it's
tricky though it is a relatively closed
position so I might get away with those
there was some this sluggish development
there should be five again was and in
the mix
and his the c5 bishop is a slightly
annoying Pisa
I cannot nuclear f8 bishop very much and
i don't want to play f6 okay now he's
opening up there
I know that's very debatable this
decision but I'd like to get my things
developed him
that should be too bad
Bishop g6
I don't mind mind really I can go to
have seven then and maybe do something
change file yeah okay that's not a bad
move for white but it's nothing that I
particularly feared King is okay on f7 I
think you can play c4 maybe but in my
development nowis is kind of okay and
this pawn structure looks a bit weakest
with a 6g 6 but he has no LightSquared
bishop anymore
and without that it should be okay yeah
I go d4 now that's very important the
position is not opening up Oh surprising
he's going for that yeah I thought I'm
very okay I mean again I cannot really
tell you what I think what he should
have played but this is not bothering me
very much at all
I can even do you think about grabbing
pawns which should be form or queen a
form Queen a for maybe
I really believe in the center just go
back on d3 check yeah let's give the
check him check used to use the pods b7
is hanging you can give it this is just
really just a check I think h5 there is
he only has one check I go to g8 and
that's it
check oops
ok so takes f6 yeah this is full full
fledged swindling mode yeah but okay so
it's kind of tricky let's let's see I
can probably start with that move if I
takes I have taken f6 mm I'm not sure
about it okay come on let's let's I go
for a practical choice and just play it
in a way that my King has a bit safer
the d2 pawn is very strong
maybe I could have taken I don't know f6
I'm sometimes a bit too afraid of things
not sure in this particular case
and I have to have to move
my rook edge three rookie three
is tricky especially considering the
time but f-for Hank so he cannot easily
move the rook I don't know to be quick
here just for Roxy one at one moment I
can take here why can I not take I don't
get it
time warning okay let's grab
should be 5 is a very strong next can
check with the Queen right
well plate everything sound everything's
covered hmm channa the big question was
could I have taken the bishop or not I
really don't know around here it starts
to get downhill for white my computer
actually already gives me a pretty
substantial advantage because I get to
fall in and this is this is really not
great I'm just better developed here got
more pieces in the game this is not a
good piece here and here black really is
just fine with the pastor on the D file
but this is another proof by the compet
wants to play Bishop b4 yeah I
considered that but I wasn't sure if I
really want to get ya want to take this
route Jam
yeah computer once ok computer says rook
a 1 and I have to go back and that's
really true that says that dis objection
with the movement and this is just good
for black out yeah and this is a winner
winning position for black in computer
terms but you still have to be careful
of course traffic Queen before KD 2 was
also not exactly bad check yet he took
their I mean I don't know can I take
that's the question what is the computer
saying f6 wide wins yeah I had this
hunch I mean quit g6 is really dangerous
and they capture I have no defense here
no defensive pieces yeah so I cannot
take and I have to play something else
ok then this was really a good decision
I wasn't completely sure and this is
winning all along Queen e2 is a bit
stronger but yeah I think I can I can be
satisfied that that was some reasonably
well well defended I wasn't completely
sure about
Bishop capture but it really disuse when
I looked at this but there's really is
no move ya if I go here just I have
seven as killing and he threatens that
anyway now okay that that's really not
playable at all oh okay well thanks for
watching